[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the calmness
at the I newspaper Ian Dunt and the
political editor at the sun on Sunday
Kate Ferguson they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
for the front of the financial times
looks at the UK government's energy
plans with the headline Renewables
groups face price caps
the eye says Liz trust has had fraught
disagreements with business secretary
Jacob Marie smog over how to prevent
energy blackouts this winter
number 10 hit by Rao over brexit
freedoms reads the front of the Daily
Express as they look at another alleged
cabinet Rift
The star looks at Panic buyers who were
stockpiling candles over fears of a
blackout this winter
on the telegraph's front page is the
sacking of Tory Minister Connor Burns
who has had the whip removed over claims
of serious misconduct
this is also the story on the front of
the Guardian
the time says parents could be directly
handed cash payouts with Liz truss
looking at overhauling the child care
system
The Daily Mail leads with a prescription
soup and shakes diet which is set to be
offered on the NHS claiming to reverse
type 2 diabetes
but the mirror says the NHS is suffering
from a booster job crisis with millions
of over 50s yet to receive their booster
as covert cases begin to rise again
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
columnist at the eye newspaper Ian Dunt
and political editor at the sun on
Sunday Kate Ferguson welcome to you both
let us start with the front page of the
Telegraph and their headline Minister
sacked Connor Burns stripped of whip
over at serious misconduct claims take
us into this story in
yeah so this makes the front page of
several papers you'll notice even though
she's
only been in power really for about a
month most of which was taken up by the
death of the queen and even though she's
only just ended the Conservative Party
Conference and should have a period of
Calm before Parliament starts up next
week uh the front pages right now are
like the last days of road for the
conservative party it's an absolutely
nightmare sort of cabinet Rift off the
cabinet Rift off the cabinet Rift and
Scandal this one falls in the Scandal
category over events that took place
towering details from the coverage so
far during the Tory Party Conference
very much of the sort that we saw you
know during the very long slow end of
the Johnson Administration and she has
acted much faster than Johnson trusted
striptum of the weight very very quickly
um so now you sort of look to it as
essentially an assessment of well is
there going to be a by-election there
um because if so the Tories are probably
going to lose there's only a 10 000
majority would be considered perfectly
substantial most of the time but given
the state of the party right now you
wouldn't hedge any bets on them
um so just another pretty poisonous
toxic story to add to the pile of
poisonous toxic stories that Liz trust
faces on the front pages of the
newspaper this evening uh and Kate
Connor Burns has promised to clear his
name expressing shock that he hasn't
been given details of the claim against
him
yeah this was a story we wrote earlier
today on the son's website actually
Colin Burns a newly appointed trade
Minister been suspended from the
Parliamentary Tory party and sacked as a
government Minister over this claim of
serious misconduct alleged to have
happened at the Tory Party Conference at
the busy Hotel bar now we don't know
much about the allegations so there's no
point speculating about the precise
details but it's important to note that
Conor has said he's he thinks he's
innocent of any wrongdoing and he's
vowing to clear his name but it is true
isn't it that this is yet another blow
for the Liz truss regime it's only in
its infancy it's only four weeks ago she
was crowned Tory leader and our prime
minister but already we've seen
um cabinet Rifts over things people
openly breathing against Liz and now the
sort of first of all now a scandal about
the behavior of one of her front benches
which is never a good place for a
government
and Ian the guardian reminds us that
Connor Burns is the sixth conservative
MP to have had the whip withdrawn or to
have quit politics in the past 18 months
over allegations of misconduct
yeah I mean I mean in fact the numbers
go further than that if you look across
the parliament I mean this Parliament I
don't think we're recognizing it quite
as it happens
um because we live in a very high
sort of volatility of news and have done
for the last few years now and but
actually that the degree of sort of of
allegations of sleeves and behavior is
really quite severe and happening in an
alarming rate to the point where you
really start having to ask questions
about the culture and of course look at
party conferences
um it is
it's there's a lot of alcohol
um the events go on very late into the
night anyone that's attended will sort
of say you know these things people are
still going home three four in the
morning there's a lot of political types
who are all together finally and having
rather too good a time and so typically
speaking you get events like this but
most of the time when people are in
Parliament MPS and ministers have a lot
of people under them they have little
private offices which are essentially
their own sort of SME their own small
business where they can do pretty much
what they like and behave that they want
so when you get allegations like this
the reason that they're taking very
seriously is because in their day-to-day
life they do have a lot of people around
them who are potentially vulnerable to
that behavior
let's move on to the eye your paper Ian
but Kate if you take us into this story
about uh riffs in the cabinet in terms
of the handling of the energy crisis and
namely between the Prime Minister and
Jacob Bruce MOG
yeah it wasn't so long ago that stories
of cabinet Rifts would have been quite
rare but now they seem to a penny to be
honest this is the follow-up to a story
that's been rumbling on for a couple of
days now Liz truss has blocked this big
campaign Jacob Reese MOG have business
secretary wanted to do so the cap the
government were looking at whether or
not to launch a PR Blitz this winter to
urge Brits to
um cut back on their energy use turn the
thermostat down a little bit turn
radiators off in rooms that you're not
using Jacob Bruce mock the
um business secretary was apparently in
favor of this but it seems to have been
killed by Liz truss who thinks it would
be too nannying now it's funny because
if you know Jacob he's not a
particularly Nanny State Tori so for one
of his proposals to be dismissed as
nanny statism is really quite something
I think that the issue they were
probably wear or that they were weighing
up back in Downing Street was
do you need to do this PR campaign would
it be useful or importantly could it
actually have a could it actually
backfire because if you tell people to
cut back on their energy use to turn
down the thermostat then there is a risk
isn't there that elderly people
vulnerable people might take that advice
a little bit too far and could end up um
putting their own health at risk and I
think that was the concern and Downing
Street so that may have played into it
too but I think more broadly what this
speaks to is this sort of extraordinary
political time we're living within where
a newly crowned prime minister who
should be commanding the loyalty and
authority of her parliamentary party and
her cabinet it's been pretty openly
briefed against by even quite close
allies remember Jacob battle is the
leader and was one of her most very cool
backers yes that is an interesting point
in isn't it I mean the the the prime
minister's reasoning is that they don't
want to be a nanny State and they don't
want to tell people what to do
well I mean the nanny State argument is
just one of the most absurd things I've
heard in weeks even from her I mean
there's not many speciesism because
you're not telling people what to do
you're offering advice and you're doing
it on the basis of both people's
personal interests of paying less money
for the energy but also the national
interest like we're in a period She
likes to talk a lot about bitum but this
is actually one of those moments where
you can legitimately talk about Putin we
don't know the way that he's going to
behave over this winter we don't know
what the effects of the cold snap is the
basic responsibility of government is to
be able to put out messages to people
helping them with the kind of decisions
they can do in the National and in their
personal interests and to not be able to
see the gap between that and debates
about you know sugary drinks or
something it indicates either that
people just don't understand what words
are or that their brains just aren't
even understanding the concept that
they're being met with so the argument
she's putting forward are really very
very odd indeed but I agree that the
most interesting thing that's going on
in here it's just the level of
internation cabinet counter things like
I mean this is the kind of thing you
know do you remember right at the end of
Gordon Brown's period as prime minister
it might have got to this point you know
maybe right at the end of the Boris
Johnson's time it got to about this
point she somehow managed to achieve it
in a matter of weeks and that end of
itself was the kind of thing you should
call to Guinness book with the record
okay in and Kate we are going to take a
break there
coming up uh
stories including this on the front of
the telegraph Biden's nuclear Armageddon
warning unwise says macron stay with us
for more
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me columnist at the
eye newspaper Ian Dunn and political
editor at the sun Kate Ferguson let us
take a look at the telegrapher from
Paige and this is the story regarding
President Biden's Armageddon comment
um National Security officials
really uh saying to the American people
that his comments were not triggered by
any new intelligence that Vladimir Putin
Was preparing to use a nuclear weapon in
Ukraine because of course that that is
the worry isn't it Kate
yeah I mean we've heard haven't we over
recent weeks this mounting fear that
Putin might use nuclear weapons in that
war and it seems that Biden today has
gone all out and suggested that if he
doesn't use those nukes it will be
nuclear Armageddon now it appears that
his officials have quickly tried to
scramble and sort of reset the record
and insist that it's not that the US
president knows something we don't know
and that we're not on the verge of the
global nuclear meltdown but still it's
very alarming and not not really what
you wanted to hear interestingly in this
piece though it also has some quotes
from zelenski who I think has done an
interview tonight with the BBC and so
lensky also says we are very concerned
that Putin could use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine they think that Putin is
starting to lay the ground for the use
of nuclear weapons domestically in
Russia by preparing his people for it so
it could be it is the most real threat
it's strange isn't it there's this
phrase that's being used at the moment
use of tactical and nuclear weapons by
Russia and Ukraine I think most of us
aren't that sure exactly what tactical
nuclear weapons are I think they're
basically nuclear weapons that aren't
the biggest and baddest and most
dangerous in the world they're slightly
smaller versions of nuclear weapons but
either way incredibly alarming that
we're talking about the possible use of
them in Europe or indeed anywhere in the
world yes and we're saying that
President Biden's comments were off
script um at an event in New York and
this is exactly what he said we have not
faced the prospect of Armageddon since
Kennedy and the Cuban Missile Crisis I
don't think there's any such thing as
the ability to easily use a tactical
nuclear weapon and not end up with
Armageddon
yeah it's not massively helpful he's uh
Biden is a good man and he's a good
president the stuff he was doing with
cannabis 24 hours ago was really
Progressive and rational and liberal and
terribly sensible
um he does however have these moments of
ad-libbing on tremendously sensitive
dangerous topics and this is a pretty
good example of it we know what the risk
calculation is with Putin he threatened
nuclear weapons right at the beginning
of this thing in in that sense the risk
calculation hasn't changed except the
things aren't working for Putin I think
no one really even in the hearts of it
understands
essentially whether he's saying I mean
really that's what it comes down to
because only an insane person would use
that weapon in this scenario it won't
save him and it will just cause
suffering the likes of which we haven't
seen in our lifetime so really the risk
calculation Remains the Same but his
threats will become more and more
belligerent
the more humiliated he is in Ukraine and
right now day by day he's getting more
and more humiliated it would just be
helpful if the US president wasn't
necessarily echoing the message that he
was trying to get out there as it was
happening
Ian and Kate thank you so much for
taking us through the papers I didn't
have time to get to the the marriage is
the story about uh older people not
taking their covered boosters and that's
uh amid fears of a growing uh deadly
Autumn wave of the disease